Hi everyone, my name is Sai Vennam with the IBM Cloud team.
Today we want to talk about Managed Kubernetes.
Kubernetes is an open source platform
allowing you to run your containerized workloads.
Manage Kubernetes on the other hand
is a service provided by cloud providers
and comes with a number of advantages.
For one,
it's very easy to spin up new Kubernetes clusters from scratch
and add additional computing power in response to load.
In addition,
it allows you to integrate with cutting-edge open source capabilities,
as well as familiar cloud provider services.
Finally, you get peace of mind with security across the board.
Let's go through an example of spinning up a Kubernetes cluster
on IBM Cloud Kubernetes Service.
First we'll choose the name for the cluster,
as well as the region that we want to spin it up in.
We can drill in deeper and choose the exact datacenter
that we want our cluster to live in.
In addition, we can also choose a multi-zone cluster.
This allows us to spread our Kubernetes cluster
across multiple datacenters in the same region.
This gives us high availability
if anything went wrong with one of the data centers.
Next, we can choose the flavor for the computing power
for this Kubernetes cluster.
We can stick with virtual computing, or even bare metal.
Bare metal allows you to get dedicated access to the entire machine,
allowing you to avoid that "noisy neighbor" issue.
Next you can even define GPUs for your compute power,
in case you had something like machine learning,
or image or video processing
that can take advantage of GPUs.
Finally, scrolling down to the bottom,
we can choose a number of worker nodes that we want to spin up,
and go ahead and create that cluster.
In a few minutes, your Kubernetes cluster will be provisioned
and ready to use.
Kubernetes is an open source platform
and is a part of the Cloud Native Computing Foundation.
To ensure portability of your workloads across any Kubernetes Service Provider,
the CNCF provides conformance testing.
This enables you to avoid vendor lock-in
and even allows you to do multi-cloud deployments
of your Kubernetes based applications.
Here at IBM we're strong proponents of open standards,
as well as projects in the open source community.
These include those in the CNCF,
as well as projects like Istio and Knative.
In fact, you can try managed Istio and managed Knative today
on IBM Cloud Kubernetes Service.
Outside of those managed offerings,
we also offer tutorials and documentation
to integrate with cutting edge open source capabilities,
as well as IBM tooling and offerings.
Finally, let's talk about security.
Security is something that should be integrated
into every stage of your DevOps work flow.
With IBM Cloud Kubernetes Service
we'll make sure you're protected every step of the way.
First, we have trusted private registries
that scan your images for any vulnerabilities.
Second, we will make sure that those images are scanned
as they're being pushed into a  Kubernetes cluster.
Behind the scenes,
we're always making sure that
any vulnerabilities in the technology stack that powers your cluster
are caught right away.
Thanks for watching this quick overview of Manage Kubernetes Services.
If you like this video or have any questions
be sure to drop a comment below.
Stay tuned for more videos like this in the future
and be sure to like and subscribe.